It is empowering, or at least therapeutic, in these dark times to imagine what a
time literate society might look like. In
his last public interview Kurt Vonnegut
said, "I'll tell you one thing no cabinet
has ever had is a secretary of the
future. And there are no plans at all for
my grandchildren and my
great-grandchildren." Let us adopt
Vonnegut's suggestion as our first
proposal: a representative for the yet to
be born to serve among the top advisors
to the president. The Department of the
Future would set in motion a realignment
of priorities in all aspects of society.
And now we should cue some triumphant
music, I think. The secretary will declare
some new national holidays: Aldo Leopold,
Rachel Carson, or Chief Seattle
Days to honor great long-term thinkers.
Photosynthesis and Carbonate Rock Week—a time to celebrate the mighty legions of
coccolithophores and others who have kept the planet from becoming a runaway
greenhouse. Resource conservation would again become a core value and patriotic
virtue. Tax incentives and subsidies
would be rebalanced toward rewarding
long-term stewardship over short-term
exploitation. Putting a price on carbon
will help us get a grip on our fossil
fuel addictions, sober up, and let us
prepare for the natural disasters that
will happen without our assistance, like
the hundreds of large earthquakes that
will happen around the globe in the next
century, rather than expending resources
on self-created climate catastrophes.
Poverty and class-based disparity of
opportunity would be recognized as
problems with deep historical roots that
cannot be solved without sustained
commitment over commensurate timescales into the future. Public school teachers
and others whose work represents an
investment in the future would be paid
well and held in high esteem.
Geology would be fully integrated into
science curricula, perhaps serving as a
capstone course in which students would apply physics, chemistry and biology to
the immensely complex earth system. With a solid understanding of how the planet
works, students would go on to become
educated voters who would hold public
officials accountable for wise governance of water, land and air.
Legislators, governors, and mayors who
embrace the Seven Generation Principle
would point proudly to what they are
doing and be reelected by grateful
constituents. More generally, schools
would help develop children's knowledge
of and appetite for History and Natural
History, instilling in them a deep
instinct for their place in time and a
keen curiosity to understand more.